nous sommes le 4 juillet bienvenue pour
le 78 lactu voici un résumé des
principales informations que nous allons
traiter aujourd'hui à 10h ce vendredi
les résultats du bac 2014 sont tombés
réaction à l'annonce du verdict pour les
candidats evvelinois comme chaque année
des sourires des pleurs et pour certains
il faudra se replonger dans les
révisions en vue du rattrapage la
compagnie pionnière de danse hip hop
black blomber fit ses 30 ans un
spectacle événement est en préparation
pour novembre retour sur l'histoire des
B3 avec Jean gemad son fondateur qui est
l'invité de cette édition et comme
chaque fin de semaine nous verrons aussi
l'essentiel de ce qui s'est passé sur
notre secteur des ivelines depuis lundi
du Solar d'cathlon à Versailles à l'Open
de golf à Saint-Quentin en Eveline et
puis également le verdict dans l'affaire
Kiri cet homme qui s'était opposé au
contrôle de sa femme voilée à trappe
l'an dernier les cours sont terminées
depuis 16h début officiel des vacances
élèves collégiens lycéens vont donc
pouvoir profiter pleinement du match de
la France face à l'Allemagne dans le
cadre du Mondial et puis nous sommes
allés nous rencontrer les plus jeunes
pour leur demander ce qu'ils avaient
prévu après le match que vont-ils faire
de leurs vacances c'est notre question
du jour en micro trottoir je vais
aller en
Angleterre avec une colonie et je vais
aller avec un copain à la plage après on
ira en vacances avec ma famille mais on
ne sait pas encore où je
parti chez ma Tati Isabelle je vais
aller au France àathlon et je vais aller
chez mes grands-parents à l'île de Léon
de la
piscine des choses qui sont la peinture
des choses qui sont bien on va aller en
Espagne on va aller à la place à la
piscine et puis on va faire plein de
choses amusantes les vacances bah je
vais aller au
Sénégal après que de semaines et après
après je vais aller à la piscine à la
plage et tout ça je veux y aller en
Tunisie je veux jouer au
buyot je veux je veux y aller à la
plage malgré la bonne humeur aujourd'hui
c'est une autre réalité que vient
pointer une étude de lin c'est 14 % des
enseignants de moins de 30 ans déclare
avoir été menacé ou insulté dans
l'exercice de leur profession le
directeur de l'Académie des Yvelines
était l'invité du 78 lactu hier jeudi
nous lui avons demandé sa réaction
écoutez c'est une vraie préoccupation
déjà il faut le dire là on a quelque
chose d'un peu scientifique qui nous
donne un miroir euh moi au quotidien je
peux dire que augmente chaque année les
situations particulières ù les
agressions son là le ton monte euh que
ce soit relatif d'ailleurs à des au
service rendus donc là ça concerne pas
enseignant relatif à des situations
d'élèves pour lesquelles B il y a des
accords malheureusement les signes de
préoccupation sont sur le sur le
primaire c'est là que je vois le plus
d'augmentation alors les réponses il
faut absolument épauler les enseignants
en terme de formation parce que il faut
savoir réagir il faut savoir par exemple
piloter des réunion de manière nouvelle
voir fréquemment les parents et puis il
faut qu'on ait de la communication plus
importante vers les parents c'est quand
on est plus clair depuis l'institution
scolaire envers les parents et de façon
régulière qu'on évite des crises passti
qui sont le plus souvent le résultat de
malentendu qui sont installés mais
forcément à vouloir aussi on en revient
à à la réforme à vouloir tout changer
changer les rythmes changer les
programme supprimer ou non les notes ça
crée des tensions aussi des parents qui
sont peut-être quelquefis un peu perdus
et du coup l'enseignant est en première
ligne vu en négatif ça peut être le
propos mais en renversant la perspective
ça donne justement les occasions de se
recomposer ensemble sur des sujets qui
sont importants pour tout le monde parce
que nous nous sommes les adultes on est
en train de parler des enfants qui
apprennent donc il faut susciter les
lieux de débat et de dialogue cette
étude a été publiée jeudi et vendredi
une enseignante a été poignardée à mort
par une mère d'élèves c'est à Alb Benoît
amont ministre de l'Éducation député sur
la circonscription des ivelines la 11e a
déclaré que ce drame confirmait la
nécessité de lutter contre les violences
dans et autour de l'école 30 bougies
tout autre sujet pour Black blamber la
compagnie pionnière en danse Hipop qui a
vu le jour à 50 ans Eveline va fêter ça
comme il se doit le fondateur des B3 et
l'invité de cette du ce journal de cette
édition dans un instant nous échangerons
avec jeanjemad bienvenue en plateau
bonjour pour l'instant extrait d'un
spectacle qui date de 2011 chronique du
périmètre pour se mettre dans
l'ambiance
et on va échanger donc sur ces 30 ans
sur cet anniversaire avec Jean gemad
vous êtes l'un des fondateurs
mention elle n pas là ce
so couin absolument on a vu l'un des
extraits des spectacles proposés par la
troupe il y était question de Guard des
clan dans ce spectacle d'opposition
entre des jeunes des vigiles des limites
aussi qu'impose la société et ça a
toujours été la volonté de black blomber
c'est d'avoir un message derrière la
danse on ne danse pas juste pour
s'amuser il y a un message quelquefois
grave sérieux en tout cas oui le terme
message est peut-être pas le mieux
choisi mais en tout cas il y a une
réflexion il y a quelque chose qui
dépasse la simple anecdote ou ou la
simple farce qui est présentée sur le
plateau effectivement dans cette pièce
c'est la question de l'usage de l'espace
public au-delà même de d'y pratiquer de
la danse comment se fait-il que il y a
de moins en moins d'espaces public et
d'espaces partagés aussi par le public
voilà c'est le thème central il y avait
tou il y a toujours dans chacune des
pièces cette C des spectacles cette
volonté de de réflexion et pas de
message j'ai bien entendu on vous a
souvent demander de de revenir sur ce
plateau mais si sur d'autres plateaux
télé sur la création de Black blomber
alors on va pas retracer tout
l'historique mais mais on peut quand
même repréciser que rien de prédestiné à
la naissance de cette troupe karatéka
médecin qui rencontre une chorégraphe
licencié en histoire c'est plutôt
improbable ça a marché pourquoi la
rencontre était déjà improbable
peut-être ça a marché parce que parce
que Ville-Nouvelle ça a marché parce que
un élan formidable orchestré par l'État
pour que ce soit une vraie ville qui
advienne derrière tout ces murs qu'on
avait fait monter si rapidement c'est
arrivé parce que les élus les habitants
les artistes implantés il y avait le
théâre de l'unité tout ça ne peut pas
arriver s'il y a pas de d'artistes
permanents parce qu'il y a eu toute
cette toutes ces personnesl et puis il y
a eu cette
alchimie autour du Théâtre de l'Unité je
pense que le Théâtre de l'Unité a été
vraiment le l'élément les personnalités
qui ont fécondé cette sorte de capacité
à la joie cette sorte de de capacité à
croire dans le désir de pouvoir produire
nous-même notre propre récit 30 ans de
Black blomber forcément il y aura des
représentations un spectacle qui va se
préparer pour l'occasion ce sera en
novembre on va y venir auparavant votre
premier souvenir avec la
troupe le moment où vous êtes dit
peut-être aussi ah c'est bon ça va
marcher ça marche c'est c'est ça que je
voulais ça marche
oh c'est difficile ça parce que c'est
une construction
progressive la première fois qu'on s'est
montré avec le nom de Black blomber
c'était au parc
etan le directeur de l'époque je m'en
veux de pas me souvenir de son nom mais
je me rappelle bien de la personnalité
m'avait dit tu vas voir ça va vous
porter chance si on s'était produit sur
un plateau euh pas loin des des du
restaurant des bernaches et oh pas grand
monde il y avait une centaine de
personnes nos amis et tout et il est
probable qu'à ce moment-là je me suis
rendu compte que c'était quelque chose
dire que ça allait marcher je sais pas
c'était tous les tous les matins qu'il
fallait qu chose alors ça encore encore
enfin à ce moment-là non on se dit pas
des trucs pareils peut-être qu'après la
première représentation du parking je me
suis dit oui là il y a une c'est il y a
le potentiel d'une vraie troupe et le
fait d'avoir réussi déjà à fabriquer
quelque chose partir revenir chez nous
fabriquer quelque chose je savais déjà
que ça allait servir à faire réfléchir
d'autres éventuellement d'exemples ou de
ou de stimulant mais pas au moment où on
le faisait cette représentation du
parking c'était le 15 15 16 septembre la
toute première représentation premier
spectacle il y a 30 ans on va regarder
un nouvel extrait c'est forcément
beaucoup plus récent un extrait de
paradoxe puisque ce spectacle est
toujours en construction il y aura une
une restitution une présentation au
public ce sera à la fin de l'année en
décembre 2014 de tout cela on va en
parler voici un
extrait
de paradoxe un spectacle un peu à part
dans dans la compagnie puisque la
compagnie propose des créations mais
propose aussi de la formation là ce sont
des
apprentisdur contexte de la transmission
et dans la manière sans doute originale
puisque la compagnie s'est créée de
cette façon là paradoxe c'est un peu le
spectacle école des B3 junior al pour le
coup on leur a donné ce nom là parce que
c'est des jeunes de trappe et de 50 ans
en Yveline voilà mais des processus de
cet ordre on en a fait pendant 30 ans et
les danseurs de ces 15 dernières années
sont des danseurs issus de processus
similair que nous avons fait à
clairmontferrand à Chell à Ben enfin un
peu partout en France et et même en
Europe donc voilà c'est mais ça c'est le
c'est les juniors de Trapp 50 ans yeline
pour nous c'est quand même assez
particulier et c'était important pour
nous de bah voilà de de les inclure dans
ce parcours des 30 ans parce que parce
que voilà la vie c'est une boucle et
quand une chose se termine d'autres
d'autres commencent et pour eux aussi
comme pour leurs aînés dans les
spectacles il y a une réflexion cette
fois-ci sur l'opposition riche pauvre ce
que signifie la réussite là aussi
l'aventure spectacle c'est l'aventure de
qu'estce que c'est de fabriquer un
spectacle en quoi ça consiste alors
c'est c'est certainement d'avoir de la
technique mais c'est aussi de réfléchir
comment on va écrire quelque chose avec
de la danse puis que le produit final
c'est pas des choses qu'on dit c'est
choses qu'on voit et puis c'est de se
dire est-ce qu'on a quelque chose à
raconter parce que si tous les gens tous
les gens qui font des spectacles n'ont
pas forcément quelque chose à dire et
parfois faut prendre le temps alors au
début ils sont arrivés avec le
thème c'était un peu la vengance des
pauvres la revanche des pauvres et puis
on l'a mis en à distance on l'a mis en
réflexion et nous avons
ensemble nous sommes arrivés au sujet du
paradoxe de la richesse qu'est-ce qu'
est trs riche en fin de compte et voilà
c'est ce sujet qui sera présenté le 17
décembre à la 7 décembre à la meurise et
ça fait partie des des événements
organisés autour de de ces 30 ans et le
spectacle des 30 ans celui-ci ce sera 21
22 novembre à 20h30 et à quoi ça va
ressembler je l'ai pas précisé ce sera
au prisme àc absolument au prisme est en
cours anciennement Maison pour Tous où
est née la compagnie donc ça a du sens
pour nous d'être là évidemment à cette
époque-là c'est le 21 et 22 novembre là
je lance un appel à tous nos amis à
notre public à toutes les familles à
tous les gens qui euh ont participé de
prux de loin à ce récit pour être au
rendez-vous parce que je pense que
au-delà de notre anniversaire c'est une
manière de dire l'importance du récit
local quand il est fabriqué par les
habitants donc rendez-vous hein
entendez-moi bien et ce spectacle
s'appelle traveling il a pour vocation
de euh repasser au travers du répertoire
que Christine a mis en place depuis elle
1990 et de tenir un nouveau propos ou
peut-être un propos nouveau en tout cas
quelque chose qui ne soit pas
nostalgique et j'espère pas chiant voilà
le but ce sera de s'amuser vous pouvez
vous impliquer si vous le souhaitez et
puis parcourir le site internet qui a
été mis en place à cette occasion
b3-les30 ans.fr là c'est intéressant
parce que pour ceux qui qui connaissent
moins on va découvrir toute l'histoire
et vous l'avez fait sous forme de
publication ça va être alimenté
régulièrement jusqu'à fin il y a des
gens qui vont réaliser que on se les ait
pas mis pendant 30 ans et il y a des
documents on voit des on voit des photos
il y a des des des vidéos aussi qui sont
publier des des archives l'idée c'est de
montrer toute cette richesse absolument
et là je lance un autre appel à tous les
gens qui pourraient avoir aussi des
éléments de cette histoire ou même des
transversales des anecdotes qui se sont
produites parce que c'est cette histoire
est tellement immense que personne ne
peut prétendre en faire le contour c'est
une sorte de mythe mais ce qui est
intéressant c'est de passer à travers
les anecdotes les transversales de ce
mythe les petites histoires celles de
coulisse et cetera et nous allons
essayer de réunir dans un temps fort que
pour le moment nous essayons de produire
après le spectacle donc qui serait une
sorte
d'AF soit le 21 2 soit le 17 mais je
vous le dirai lorsque nous nous
retrouverons au mois de septembre encs
de construction mais nous essayons de
construir un temp fort autour des
anciens autour de tous les artistes et
toutes les personnalités et pas
simplement artistes qui ont participé à
ce récit de telle sorte à faire
apparaître oui c'est ça quelques
transversales pour passer un bon moment
autour de cette histoire voilà date à
retenir 21 22 novembre au prisme à en
cours le spectacle pour les 30 ans le 17
décembre la C à la merurise attrape pour
découvrir le travail des des juniors
avec cette pièce qui est créée qui est
toujours en création paradoxe et puis il
y aura encore d'autres événements mais
vous aurez l'occasion de revenir pour
absère nen àcanniversaire de la blackber
c'est unogan qui aié à l'équipe de
France de footall en 98 vous en pensez
quoi c'était une bonne idée d'abord
j'étais super fier puisque c'est moi qui
a créé ce nom qui l' déposé la belle
dessusah on l'avait déposé on nous l'a
repiqué on l'a retrouvé enfin bon ça
c'est on peut passer une émission à se
raconter ça sur le droit et la propriété
intellectuelle c'est intéressant
d'ailleurs non mais même c'est
intéressant parce que c'est une minorité
c'est les black blambur gay qui sont
emparés du nom un jour où moi je ne
savais pas qu'il fallait le renouveler
tous les 10 ans donc voilà mais c'est un
jour je vous raconterai cette histoire
non mais c'est pas grave d'ailleurs
parce que nous on leur a dit préciser
que vous êtes gay c'est tout pour qu'il
confondent pas avec une compagnie qui
elle a pour objet de faire de la danse
voilà donc euh sur cette histoire là il
y a pas grandchose à dire sur la réalité
de Black blomber et peut-être pour
revenir aussi à l'actualité et puis pour
revenir aussi à la réalité du moment il
a ce match Allemagne black blomber c'est
une réalité très fier et
ensuite alors voilà mais je vais essayer
j'arrive pas le faire court mais je
voudrais dire un truc làdessus je vrais
dire que c'est une bonne chose que le
temps d'une coupe du monde on puisse
avoir un commun et un désir commun qui
nous permette de faire un peuple de gens
qui se parlent qui se sourient qui se
racontent des choses voilà et pour moi
l'intérêt de la Coupe du Monde c'est ça
donc je forme le vœux que l'équipe de
France évidemment aille le plus loin
possible et que cette notion le terme de
black blomber c'est un bon signe
d'ailleurs si le terme de Black blomber
remonte ça veut dire qu'on a passé les
quarts de finale et pour nous évidemment
c'est un retour formidable et pour ceux
qui nous suivent vendredi à 18h ou à 19h
pour la pour la rediffusion bien sûr un
bon courage au bleu et puis pour ceux
qui verront la redffusion de ce journal
forcément vous aurez déjà le verdict de
ce cruel match merci beaucoup Jean géal
on revient à l'actualité du jour
l'actualité du vendredi soulousagement
ou déception pas de demi-mesure en tout
cas à 10h ce vendredi matin pour les
candidats au baccalauréat ils ont
découvert leurs résultats pour certains
le début du rattrapage voici quelques
réactions et notamment celle de
cololline au lycée Hoche à Versailles
que nous avons suivi pendant toutes ces
épreuve Mathilde
capberne normalement je suis censée
l'avir après j'espère que je l'aurai en
effet mais ça devrait aller je pense ce
vendredi matin Coline et les 17000
candidats du baccalauréat ont attendu
patiemment devant les gris du lycée
alors que les portes s'ouvrent le pas se
presse vers les résultats et les
premières exclamations de joie se font
entendre oui assez bien B so assez bien
je suis trop content je pensais vraiment
pas l'avoir pour le coup oui oui mention
Très Bien mention Très Bien ouais je
l'ai eu avec mention assez bien sympa
bien
ouais non je peux sens bien verdict pour
Coline elle a eu son bac avec mention
assez bien entre embrassade et deux
trois larmes les yeux rivés sur leur
téléphone portable Coline et ses
camarades doivent rassurer leur
famille il faut que j'appelle ma
grand-mère après certains n'ont pas
trouvé leur noms sur les listes ils
passent au rattrapage dès lundi le choix
des matières est donc important
le choix des matières est très simple il
faut prendre les matières où la note est
la plus médiocre pour avoir un
différentiel de points maximum donc on
est là pour les aider mais le choix en
fait est très très simple une fois
l'excitation retombé les bacheliers vont
chercher leur notes les résultats sont
parfois étonnants alors en
filo le bac en poche les bacheliers
peuvent maintenant se détendre et penser
aux études supérieursine préparera dès
septembre une licence en administration
économique et social à l'université
Versailles Saint-Quentin ça y est c'est
fait ça y est c'est fait ouais ben je
suis contente d'avoir les résultats je
suis contente d'avoir mes notes je suis
un peu déçu en histoire mais sinon je
suis plutôt contente dans l'ensemble
donc ça va benah moi j'aiété prise à à
Saint-Quentin à es donc c'était mon
premier vœux donc je suis contente après
je crois que tout tout ce qui est
inscription ça se fait sur internet donc
ça c'est vite fait et après bah vacances
je pars des dimanches donc après je
serai pratiquement pas là des vacances
donc c'est cool C année le lycée hoch
maintient ses 99 % de réussite sur 400
élèves seulement 5 vont au rattrapage
150 élèves ont reçu la mention très
bien nous poursuivons ce journal avec
l'essentiel de la semaine comme chaque
vendredi et le verdict dans l'affaire
Michael Kirry l'homme qui s'était opposé
au contrôle d'identité de sa femme
portant le voile intégral il est c de 3
mois de prison avec surc à sorti de 1000
€ d'amende Antony était mardi après-midi
à la cour d'appel de
Versailles sa peine a finalement été
confirmée comme en première instance
Michael Kiri a été condamné à 3 mois de
prison avec surcis par la cour d'appel
de Versailles le jeune homme converti à
l'islam à 16 ans s'était violamment
interposé au contrôle d'identité de sa
femme Cassandra Belin portant le nikab
en juillet 2013 à trappe conforme au
réquisition du parquet cette
condamnation est assortie d'une amende
de 1000 € auquelle s'ajoute désormais
150 € que devra verser Michael Kirry aux
trois policiers ayant effectué ce
contrôle d'identité cette décision
intervient quelques heures après un
arrêt de la Cour européenne des droits
de l'homme de Strasbourg jugeant
légitime l'interdiction de voile
intégrale en France validant ainsi la
loi du 11 octobre 2010 l'épouse de
Michael Kiri Cassandra Belin condamné
elle à un mois de prison avec surc pour
avoir insulter ses policiers pendant le
contrôle sera rejugé le 22 octobre pour
rappel en juillet 2013 ce contrôle avait
entraîné de violents affronttements
entre forces de l'ordre et jeunes dans
la
ville le Solard Décathlon compétition
internationale autour de la maison de
demain se poursuit à Versailles les
réalisations des étudiants ingénieurs
prennent forme sous les yeux du jury
Olivier Maniscalco a suivi notamment les
compétiteurs
suisses 4e jour de compétition pour le
Solar d'cathlon de versaill après avoir
monté leur maison solaire les équipes
sont désormais évaluées par un jury de
spécialistes trois critères ont déjà été
jugés bilan énergétique confort des
maisons et communication autour du
projet une communication que l'équipe
suisse originaire de Lucerne soigne
auprès du public en proposant par
exemple des parasols gratuits aux
visiteurs il faut dire que leur projet
Luc est basé sur le partage trois pièces
composent la maison solaire une privée
avec chambre et salle d'eau une autre
semi-privée avec cuisine et une dernière
où tout le monde peut se rendre c'est
ensuite grâce à une application sur sur
smartphone et tablette que le tout sera
agencé le but de l'équipe mieux utiliser
l'espace urbain de plus en plus
restreint notre concept c'est de
partager de partager les choses qui qui
on possède de partager la place où on
habite ça vient de de l'histoire alors
on a le le concept de partager dans le
dans le paysan qui habite ensemble qui
travaill ensemble ça
s'appelle pas je sais pas le mot
français mais on a transformé ce modèle
et on a
l'utilise pour nous oui si pour
l'ensemble des équipes les 10 jours de
montage ont été suffisants pour proposer
une maison apte à la compétition la team
parisienne livelb elle n'a toujours pas
terminé son chantier être bâtisseur ça
ne s'improvise pas surtout sans
professionnel pour encadrer le montage
c'est un projet vraiment difficile donc
il fallait gérer tout l'inclination
desorti qu' forme la barrière et donc
c'est toujours à contrôler il sont
plusieurs choses à contrôler on a décalé
de plus en plus il fallait avoir un peu
plus de temps ça c'est sûr parce que
pour un projet de cette dimension là
aussi avec la difficulté de de la
structure qu'on a c'est vraiment pas
beaucoup 10 jours siiv lib est
malheureusement déjà hors course pour
une victoire au solar 2014 la France
peut encore compter sur un autre projet
tricolore pour l'instant 5e au
classement les nanté de Philias gardent
en effet toutes leurs chance mais avec
10 jours restant dév
la route est encore
longue côté sport l'actualité dans les
evelins c'est l'Alstom Open de France
les meilleurs mondiaux de golf se
disputent ce trophée sur le parcours de
l'Albatros lors du premier tour
l'Américain Kevin Stadler a pris la tête
devant le vainqueur de 2012 quant au
premier français il est déjà loin
derrière la compétition se déroule
jusqu'à dimanche soir et en marche de la
compétition Thierry braayard secrétaire
d'État au sport est venu sur le parcours
de l'Open rencontrer les sportifs et
surtout rappeler le le soutien de l'État
en vue de l'organisation de la rider Cup
sur ce site la compétition qui oppose
les meilleurs golfeurs européens aux
meilleurs américains se déroulera en
2018 à saint-quenttin en Yveline Olivier
Maniscalco premier jour de compétition à
l'Open de France sur le Golf National de
saint-quanttin en Yveline pour ce
tournoi majeur sur le circuit européen
les élus locaux et français ont fait le
déplacement notamment Tiry Brayard
secrétaire d'État chargé des sports qui
peut compter sur jeanv de Velde ancien
pro et directeur du tournoi pour lui
expliquer l'effet rétro de la balle de
golf quel est le geste pour que la BAL
une fois qu'elle atterrit reparère la
prend alors coince entre la terre et la
face de CL comme la face de CL il y a
des rur à l'intérieur la balle s'écrase
sur les rur commence à tourner en
arrière ce qu'on appelle le làand quand
elle est en
l'ourouappe le sol fait généralementot
en avant et deè
robotême revent outre l'Open de France
l'autre sujet de discussion c'est 2018
et le Golf National de Saint-Quentin qui
accueillera la célèbre rider Cup alors
forcément avec la venue du secrétaire
d'État les élus locaux attendent des
réponses notamment sur le financement
d'un tel événement l'engagement de
l'État vous savez moi j'ai suivi
d'autres opérations notamment le
Vélodrome et bien il a fallu que chaque
fois qu'un nouveau ministre arrivé
retourner dans le bureau du ministre
pour que l'État à nouveau nous confirme
donc moi je suis comme Saint- Thomas je
ne crois que ce que je vois je ne crois
que ce que j'entends et les engagements
des uns j'espère que sont ils seront
respecté par les autres l'État va va
soutenir et soutient déjà et va soutenir
la rider Cup je crois que c'est on peut
pas avoir plus belle exposition et c'est
bien parce que ça accompagnera la
politique que je vous disais de
popularisation le golf aujourd'hui est
quasiment un des sports les les plus
pratiqués en France qui aurait dit ça il
y a il y a 20 ans et ben je pense qu'il
faut continuer
en attendant la rider Cup les élus ont
pu assister au départ mitigé de Victor
du Buisson numéro 1 français qui
comptait déjà qu coups au-dessus du par
après de
trous merci de nous avoir suivi le
journal revient lundi aux mêmes heur
dernière semaine en direct avec nos
invités avant de faire une pause et de
se retrouver en septembre d'ici là
excellent excellent
weekend